well the US government is taking Google
to court over antitrust allegations
prosecutors will argue that the company
used unfair practices to become the most
popular and dominant search engine by
far Colin Baker
explains think about how you search the
web you pull out your phone and type a
question chances are you're already
using Google there are other search
engines but 90% of the world uses Google
to find the information they want and
search is what makes Google and its
parenty alphabet one of the most
profitable firms on the planet here's
how it works you want to find that
coffee shop advertisers like the nearby
ones have already put in bids for the
keywords you're going to look for if
they've bid high enough or the keywords
are specific enough their business will
pop up first you might go buy a coffee
but when you click the ad the coffee
shop pays Google a fee that's Google ads
but as you browse the web using Google
it's cookies and Bots follow you
building a profile that will Target
other companies advertising on other
websites to you you can turn the
trackers off but you probably won't and
it's all extremely profitable Google
made more than
$160 billion last year from the ads in
search but why does Google often come up
first when you purchase a new mobile
device according to the US it's because
the company paid Apple Motorola Samsung
and others billions ions of dollars to
be the default search option Google
acknowledges the deals but doesn't
specify the terms the US says that's
unfair so it's using a law from the turn
of the 19th century to stop it the
Sherman Act simply says you cannot have
anti-competitive agreements and you
cannot monopolize or attempt to
monopolize that's all it says the last
time the US government took on a tech
company this big was in the 1990s the
target was Microsoft and Bill Gates had
to testify that his company wasn't
forcing out competing internet browsers
Microsoft lost it was broken up then it
appealed and paid a penalty more than a
generation later Microsoft is now
Google's toughest search competitor
thanks to new AI powerered search
options in bing I think the reason why
now is just that we have a more
Progressive regime that's willing to go
after some of these cases and obviously
this was started in 2020 so it isn't the
um you know the Biden Administration
alone just going after it but uh there's
just been a larger push to go after a
lot of these tech companies now because
they've gotten so large Google says it
makes a powerful and fair product that
helps businesses grow and if users want
to choose a different Search tool they
can but this is just one of several
cases the US is making against the
Giants of Silicon
Valley well Patty Cain is live for us in
Washington DC with more on this story I
suppose what we're what we're wondering
is what can we expect from this case in
court Patty
well what's happening right now is the
attorneys for the Department of Justice
and then the ATT an attorney
representing the more than a dozen
states that have joined the lawsuit
they've just now finished opening
arguments about an hour and a half judge
gave about a 20-minute break and so I
expect right about now lawyers for
Google are giving their side of the case
uh it's expected to take about 10 weeks
of testimony and experts say it is going
to take months for the judge to decide
this uh it could actually not come down
till 2024 it isn't a jury trial so it's
been interesting the judge has been
interjecting questions on sort of legal
grounds definitions so keeping the
lawyers on their toes a bit but as Colin
mentioned this really comes down to is
Google an illegal Monopoly what's an
illegal Monopoly well it's a company
that's so big that no other company
could possibly compete with them and
again at the heart of this case is that
default setting so we did get a little
bit of news in the courtroom today the
attorneys for the justice department say
say that Google spends 10 billion more
than10 billion a year to get those
default settings on your computer on
your iPhone now Google for its part says
uh look people use our search engine
we're the dominant Force because it's
such a good search engine and people can
change their default settings the answer
from the justice department as they
finished up their opening arguments was
well if defaults don't matter then why
is Google willing to pay billions of
dollars for them so again opening
argument underway gole up next well it's
still obviously very noisy where you are
but one wonders uh through all the noise
and Buzz of what's going to happen
certainly in court how this is going to
impact on the consumer depending on
which way the verdict goes
eventually well experts will tell you
this is an absolutely huge huge Cas they
just think about how much big Tech
dominates our lives right now now so the
government says if Google if they win
one of the options that they'll look at
is asking the judge to break Google up
that would have a huge impact on Google
and alphabet and all of their
shareholders obviously but the
government also says it would increase
competition maybe a search engine could
break through that maybe has better
privacy policies for consumers it could
also lower the cost of advertising
Google has a pretty much a lock on
online advertising and they testimony in
court was that they can basically set
their own price so it could make it much
cheaper for businesses to advertise but
it's even bigger than that there are
just a handful of really big tech
companies that pretty much control our
online lives this could send the message
if Google wins that the government
cannot take those businesses on if the
government wins companies like Facebook
and meta its parent company and all the
others might get concerned that the uh
government's going to turn their
attention on them next interesting very
interesting indeed uh Pat eel ha there
for us in Washington DC thank you